أنا لا أسمي نفسي نسوية لأنني
لست بحاجة إلى هذه التسمية بنفس الطريقة التي
لا يحتاج فيها الأمريكيون الأصليون إلى تسمية
الهنود التي تعرف أنهم كانوا بالفعل من
هم ، وباعتباري مسلم ، فأنا
أؤمن بالفعل بالمساواة على مستوى أكبر بكثير
أكثر مما يمكن أن توفره النسوية
لي طوال حياتي ، لقد كان الأمر في
ذهني للتو هو أنك تعلم أن بناء
مسجد هو شيء أنا إن شاء الله
سأفعله بوضوح عندما كنت طفلاً ، لقد
كان أكثر بكثير كما تعلم أنه كان أكثر من ذلك بكثير
مبنى مادي وأنت تعلم
أنني أريد مبنى جميل مبنى جميل
وبعد ذلك مع تقدمي في السن
تغيرت فكرتي عن هذا المسجد المثالي
بدأت أفكر في المسجد ليس فقط
كمبنى مادي ولكن كمساحة مجتمعية
ومكان للإلهام في
المكان الذي يمكن أن تشكل فيه
حركة في الواقع ، الشيء الأكثر شيوعًا الذي
يخطئ الناس فيه بشأن مسجد النساء
هو أنهم يعتقدون أنه
رد فعل للمساجد الموجودة
ويعتقدون أن النساء يهربن من الرجال
، فليس كل ما تفعله هذه الكاميرا
لقد كان مشروع مسجد النساء في أمريكا حقًا
مشروعًا نابع من الحب
والإلهام والعاطفة ، فأنا أعمل بشكل منتظم في
موسكو ER ، وكان العنصر الوحيد للسيدات
حرفيًا مجرد الكرز في الأعلى
وهذا ما أثار اهتمام الجميع
به ولكنه حقًا  هي نسبة صغيرة
من إجمالي المشروع
بالنسبة لي